foreign
guys thank you so much for always
sending me video requests because then I
know what you guys really like
today's video request is how to choose
the right hairstyle for men
now this is one of the most important
questions that you can ask about
grooming and let's face it you want to
look good you want to look professional
you want to look neat you want to well
you just want to look good and of course
it starts with choosing the right
haircut that fits in with your face
shape and well with everything your ears
your the length of your forehead like
mine I've got a big forehead so you need
to choose carefully the problem is there
are a lot of hairstyles out there and
before you go and choose one there are a
few things that you need to take into
consideration before you choose and the
first thing is your face shape then you
need to consider your hairline your ears
your hair
your hair thickness and texture now the
biggest factor is your face shape so
let's start with that the idea here is
to always go the opposite of your face
shape so for example if you have a round
face then you don't want to choose a
hairstyle that looks around
you're not going to look good in it you
can try a spiky haircut a messy wave
style a side part or brushed up the hair
medium fade high fade will look good
because you need to keep the sides short
and the back as well and if your face is
really around you can also try to grow
out a beard you know that goes from
short to long not a round beard now
let's go to the other face shapes
tonight
square shape for the square shape you
need to go for a hairstyle that is less
squary if that is even a word but you
get what I mean you guys can go bold try
a buzz cut modern flat top an undercut
will also look great or a gentleman's
cut and if you have curls do close
cropped curls a quiff might also look
good for the heart shape you can try a
few different styles you can try the
classic undercut and also slick back
cool textured spikes will also work and
then fringes like a side swept you can
also give a short or medium side part a
go
try a quiff
and even longer hair like shoulder
length and then if you have a bigger
forehead you know like me then a side
part is usually the best option instead
of a push back you know or a slick back
because then your forehead is just going
to look bigger especially if if you're
slowly starting to go bold like I also
am
it's not going to look good
rectangular textured haircuts will be
the best you know and these days it is
really in you know to have a medium or
high fatal it looks good but you guys
your difference you don't have to I mean
you will look good when your hair is a
little bit longer here on the sides as
well the problem is when you shave your
hair very short here on the sides then
your face will even look skinnier
go for a classic side part crew cut you
can also try fringes
and a swept back cliff and then you can
even try a messy natural look especially
if you have curly hair
oval now you guys are blessed because
you can almost try any hairstyle and it
will look good but personally I will go
with a shorter on the sides and a little
bit longer on the top like uh quick but
then you can do it with a tapered fade
another thing that might look good is a
slick back or even just a pushback
triangle now here your jawline looks
very big compared to your head and so
what you want to do is well in most
things in life it is like this you want
to create balance so you want to have a
little bit more hair here on top you can
go for a longer crew cut a quiff
or textured spikes now let's talk about
a receding hairline you know you guys
can see through this last four or five
years I have a receding hairline right
and the worst thing that you guys can do
is grow your hair long it's not going to
look great especially if you are losing
hair you know people who go bold you
know most of the people around over 60
percent after 35
you're going to have visible signs of
hair loss and so when you can see it you
know those holes and okay this guy's
losing hair but then you grow it long
and you try to hide it you know you see
it with a lot of older people in the old
days you know when they go bold they get
this huge Fringe you know and they they
comb it over it and it just it just
looks bad cut it short you cannot style
over those bold patches it doesn't look
good with the receding hairline the same
thing keep it short
you can go for a bold look a bus cut
even a foxhawk or a short side part
because that will look a lot better
now look always remember all the tips
that I'm giving you in my videos is just
a personal guideline you know you can
still make your own decisions you're not
going to look exactly the same as
someone else who has the same phase ship
as you
you are unique so you can try different
looks and then just go with the one that
you like the most the only thing you
really need to remember when it comes to
hairstyles is there's one word
symmetry you want to create symmetry
because that will give you the best look
and now if you don't know what face
shape you have then check out this video
here and we'll help you out I'll see you
there and remember life is short so
don't waste yours cheers guys